now a lot of people think
uh uh a podcast it's sort of an audio
experience what would the excitement be
of listening to people eat pizza let me
tell you something no one enjoys a
freshly cooked homemade pie like I do
you're gonna hear me have maximum
orgasmic oh come on no you're ruined it
you were setting the whole town
what I mean by orgasmic is not in the
crude way that you guys thought what I'm
talking about is you're going to hear me
at my heightened sense of food Glory I'm
going to be tasting this pizza because I
love a good pizza actually is my
favorite food if you had asked me you
know 20 30 years ago I'd say when I
check out of this life if they said
you've got 10 minutes left what do you
want I would say a really good margarita
pizza and a glass of red wine good
because you're going tonight oh well
guess what
I'm okay I've had a good one but I would
say
um so this is I think a good audio
experience for people you're gonna hear
me really chewing swallowing and you're
gonna hear my you're going to hear my
digestive juices oh god well listen but
it's a symphony I it's one I've been
told by friends and Intimates
then when I digest put your old ear up
to the belly ew and it's like it's like
listening to Mozart and that's what
you're gonna hear tonight you're gonna
hear a man digesting food that he really
truly loves and I think a podcast has
never been used in a better way than
tonight what is the opposite of erotic I
feel like you just sterilized me well
first of all you're welcome because you
you're a d fluffer I'm a deep leopard
you know what happens when someone takes
like way too much Viagra and it won't go
away yeah they rush me in I'm flown in
from around the world
and what I do is I describe to them the
sounds of my digestive juices and
immediately
immediately their problem is gone
they're no longer a towel rack uh
everything is taken care of towel rack
no suddenly suddenly uh it's all taken
care of and that is the service that I
provide okay anyway but anyway here we
are and it is they fly you oh they fly
me out you could just call them
you know what I hadn't thought of that
that's a really good point yeah you know
what that's not on me that's not on them
they always provide a Learjet
and the carbon footprint is disgusting
and you know what now that you bring it
up I'm going to talk to them okay good
because
I mean I went to I mean the last one I
did was in Abu Dhabi
they flew me in
some very wealthy person Abu Dhabi had
accidentally he thought they were jelly
beans and it was Viagra anyway
this guy could drill through
solid slate and they were actually using
him to try and find more oil that's a
true story they they said you know
before Conan gets here we might as well
use him he hit seven gushers
and six of them were oil anyway the
point is uh six of them were oil it's uh
yeah listen the point is that I'm gonna
have a wonderful time tonight because I
do love Mia Pizza well let's talk about
that we were able to order our ideal
pizzas so Conan why don't you tell us
what your toppings are I'm gonna take a
cue from someone some of you may know
named Jordan schlansky I've done many
many remotes with him he's a famous
irritant in my life but on some things
he's correct and he said one thing to me
of the ten thousand things he said to me
there was one thing that stuck to me is
true which is the true test of a pizza
is that it should be a margarita pizza
very simple no toppings because that's
how you can really determine if it's got
determined yeah I'm fine I just had some
novocaine injected into my face but just
before I had the rum
um that's how you can determine if it's
a really good pizza so I'm I'm a purist
I like just a margarita pizza if it's
got too much stuff on it I get
distracted it and my various intestinal
juices are thrown off course Gorly how
about you I like mushrooms and just a
dash of your intestinal juices you
realize a mushroom is a fungus that's
found in the forest what do you really
like a mushroom on your pizza I don't
like Mushroom on anything but pizza and
pasta but cheese is basically a
fermented curdled milk I'm fine with
that I don't care don't talk to me don't
don't diss my cheese I mean he's just
taking your logic and applying it back
to you and what you you like I can't
even hear you sound on my headset when
you speak it doesn't work what that's
weird I know I don't understand how are
you responding I know how are you you
just responded to what I said one
responded to your hand signals no uh but
anyway he just responded directly damn
it this goddamn headset is so sexist
if you do if you want to communicate
please
please use some other form because this
isn't coming through oh okay
um no but in in all honesty uh in all
honesty in all honesty what were you
what were you gonna say in all honesty
what happened in all honesty what please
Lay It Bear yeah I'm sorry it's just too
much tonight I don't know I'm
just saying that I like to be a purist
about things and so mushrooms I wasn't I
don't want to diss the mushroom
Community because I know there are a lot
of people and my wife it's the mushroom
communities listening
we live we live we live in a volatile
time where the country is divided don't
upset Mario and Luigi man the country is
divided between mushroom and
non-mushroom and mushrooms in the game
oh that makes sense so I'm not a um I
don't love a mushroom I have to say you
know what a lot of is I love the flavor
of mushroom it's the texture I'm not a
huge texture guy but it's a little
slippery but when you get the cheese in
there and I like also I've I got tomato
chunks and basil oh good and so I think
when you mix that in you'll find you've
got a happy my brother Neil makes me
crazy because he calls it basil why does
he do that just to annoy me no exactly
and he says things like are you gonna
have some basil with that and I'll say
it's basil and he'll go hmm it's basil
no and he's wrong how do you know he's
wrong he's wrong uh he's wrong okay
trust me but he might be right we might
all be pronouncing basil wrong he might
be right with basil so thanks Neil why
are you such a devil's advocate for
Basil I don't know I just think that
you're just on your brother
right now and he's not even here to
defend himself Hey listen I like Neil
I'll go further I love Neil but I'll go
further I'm sexually attracted
well look
cheers Neil you seem to have won the
evening he's listening right now in a
curve top radio
he's an antique Radio collector anyway
uh yeah I've just got a little I'm a
little phobic about mushrooms but I
respect it I'm not I just it's not my
thing okay yeah I mean so you've taken
so you've got uh mushroom what else uh
little tomato chunks and basil excuse me
basil Jesus Christ
and it's tomato tomato chunks here we go
yeah and what do you got Sona I got
pepperoni I got olives I mushroom
that's it boy we are an adventure
I thought you were gonna keep going I
know I did too I thought I had more yeah
I got hummus why is it always
bring up hummus do you love hummus who
eats it on a pizza what's wrong with you
admit it for a second no you can't say
admit you like hummus that's if you
could say to anybody every time you talk
about food I like you bring up hummus
and I don't know why you do that because
you call it hummus first of all and you
develop who missed you do I call it
homos which is what is that it's hummus
it's almost it's hummus yeah I just
pronounce it less white than you do
okay man it's getting intense around
here I just you're the one who's like
all all up on the mush mushrooms thank
you and I'm I've got mushrooms on mine
yeah
I feel like you're coming from a place
that's very uh yeah kids unite yeah I've
got a little Judge Reinhold going and I
gotta take it easy yeah you gotta bring
up Judge Reinhold because that's a
reference that makes the kids go crazy
kids are all like oh right Beverly Hills
Cop one two and three yeah and they go
nuts Fast Times oh man fast times don't
get me started yeah the one with Fred
Savage where they swap bodies
wait what what the body swap movie with
Fred Savage and judge you know how many
bodies small movies have there been
there have been at least 15. my wife and
I considered a podcast run called potty
swap where we covered them all and then
what happened one of you sobered up both
of us immediately went that's so
horrible do you realize Child Services
would come and take your daughter away
from you
we're gonna do potty swap it's all about
we are we on knock knock is your
daughter here yeah she's over there
we're gonna do body swap where is she
going
oh god oh well time to record pepperoni
Olive mushrooms you've told us yeah oh
there is home
is it really come on hummus on there
where is it hummus oh okay admit you
know the way they can inject cheese into
the crust in some pizzas don't say it no
I'm going to admit just think for a
second if they could put if they could
put a delicious hummus into the crust
would you like to try that no I would
not that sounds disgusting it doesn't it
does it does
would you guys do it yes because it's
basically bread with pita okay I'm sorry
bread with hummus if we're gonna eat it
can you guys put hummus in their crusts
oh yeah oh yeah does someone here I'm
sorry I'm just assuming someone here has
a hypodermic needle filled with hummus
what are you talking about can someone
on the Fly inject hummus into the pizza
what kind of show is this
I thought you people were professionals
you owe me an apology you know I love
you I'm huggling
[Laughter]
want me an apology I do I do and I've
owed you an apology for many years and
you're never getting it for real